Scot as our audience might have seen
this whole film was based on a Vanity
Fair article with one of the best
headlines ever roar shock and awe it was
about the two CIA investigators and
interrogators can you tell me a little
bit about what in that article set out
to you and at what point you realized
this story really needed to pivot and
become about Dan Jones instead well
first of all thank you everyone for
coming when I started I was sort of
drawn to these two psychologists in
large part because both of my parents
were psychologists and it was somewhat
stunning to me to think about the idea
that someone would weaponize psychology
and and there was no science to back up
the idea that you could do these
techniques to extract the truth out of
people I started my research and then
the report that Dan Jones wrote for the
Senate Intelligence Committee came out
and I started pouring over the report
with Jennifer and then I was able to
meet Daniel Jones and I went out to
dinner with him and obviously he can't
tell me anything that isn't in that
report so at some point I said to him
tell me the story of how you told the
story and I became really intrigued by
the process he had to go through and it
seemed to me to be more interesting to
write a story about a truth teller than
about you know two guys who basically
ripped us off Jennifer can you talk
about the timing of all of this because
you're trying to get this film made and
meanwhile history is also unfolding yeah
when we started working on the project
five years ago Obama was still in office
and the torture program was over and at
that point we felt an urgent need to
tell the story so that history didn't
repeat itself and to try and have a
truth told and as we went through the
process it just became more and more and
more irrelevant by the day and then on
the campaign trail we have a
presidential candidate saying he would
bring back torture or worse
and at that point it just became
incredibly apparent to us that there was
an extremely urgent need but then it
continued on through as we have been
witnessing in real time now need for
checks and balances and I we hope that
the film will shed some light on the
importance of that Adam you also got to
spend some time with the real Dan Jones
what are some of the things that struck
out the most to you about him as a human
being his sense of decorum as a Senate
staffer that which I related to that
there's definitely a chain of command
that he has to follow he couldn't just
you know he didn't know it was gonna be
that long when he started doing his job
but it's not his responsibility to go
into the higher-ups office and basically
demand that he be heard and give his
opinion about it could give his opinion
period he was to present fact and let
the fact facts speak for himself and I
and even his faith in spite of what he
was uncovering within the checks and
balances in those institutions are still
very strong yeah you know he still I
mean as it is in the movie there was a
way that he can go a fast track to
getting the information out but he still
has faith in this and I think the Scott
script is a good job of showing that it
isn't the institution's overall it so
it's really a question of you know
people in positions of power and
leadership and accountability it's not
an indictment of the CIA overall look
his people within the CIA obviously
spoke out against the program so he has
a very level head and methodical
approach to work and maybe could be
characterized as obsessive but you kind
of always hope that that kind of
personality is in those rooms
you know isolated especially obviously
in in in government you know following a
moral code presenting fact as a as
opposed to opinion yeah and Jon Hamm
what's fascinating to me about this film
is I feel like we live in a culture
where you're either right or you're
wrong and people see things and they see
things that one way and it's hard to see
things any other way and yet
mr. McDonough is a little bit more in
between I feel like I'm just curious
your approach and playing this film
especially when it came to good guy bad
guy how he might be portrayed um yeah I
think we're we're sort of indoctrinated
at this point in the political landscape
to feel like everything is one opposite
or the other polar opposite and there
and the reality is most functioning
functional politics takes place in
between and as my character in the movie
says politics is messy and democracy is
messy and that doesn't mean it doesn't
work you know one of my one of the
things I'm most proud about being in
this film is that this is an example of
government being applied correctly and
working it's not perfect but this the
truth did come out a version of it and
Dennis's job was to massage that truth
out to get it out in the most fair
effective way if he would have just
stomped his foot said no we're right but
it's gonna come out this way the other
side would have pushed back and they
would have got nowhere so we had he
realized he had there had to be a
give-and-take there had to be some
negotiation there and that's 95 percent
of politics and that's the way it's
designed and it's you know it's what
we're going through right now is as a
version of that the system doing what
working by the by the directions that
they set down on a piece of paper you
know 200 some odd years ago so that's
that's what I think is is interesting
about about dennis's is that you know he
knows that the pendulum swings and he
knows that the this administration is
only in the last four maybe eight years
and so he wants to work a much longer
period if you get as much done as you
can in the time that you have one thing
that was not in the script originally as
I understand it was the torture scenes
can you talk about the decisions there's
got to actually include that and then
once you did decide to include that how
you wanted to shoot those particular
scenes they're difficult to watch yeah I
mean initially I didn't I didn't want to
include them at all because I was
worried that it would take people out of
the movie
and and then I had a conversation when I
was doing my research with a guy named
Alberto Mora and he was the Navy's
general counsel when the program was on
worked in the Pentagon and Alberto when
he found out what was going on really
stood up and tried to stop it he is a
real hero in this story and when I
interviewed him he asked me the exact
same question you're asking now and said
how are you gonna handle that and I said
I don't know I don't really want to tip
over the experience for the audience by
overwhelming them with torture and he
said if you don't show it aren't you
doing exactly what the CIA did when they
destroyed the tapes and as painful as it
is I think it's important that you know
a lot of what went on here was about
language you know enhanced interrogation
you know II I T sounds like something
like a drop of retsyn or something like
that and it's torture that's why we have
that word and a word like waterboarding
is a word but when you see what that
really means to a human being that's a
very different experience and you know
we work in a visual medium and we have
to understand what really went on here
so I guess I felt like if I didn't do it
I was I was compounding sort of the
original sin here and you know and once
I decided to do it I also really was
struck by by John McCain's speech which
closes the film which is you know it's
about us not about them so when Greg
O'Brien and I started editing the movie
I was like for every two shots of
someone being tortured or every shot of
someone being tortured what's trying to
have two shots of the torturers and and
and you know make it clear that the
people were doing this we're doing it
with masks on and I just find it
fascinating that you think you're
serving justice but you have to do it
with the ski mask on and that was
probably the thing that we spent the
most time on in post-production really
finding just the right balance where we
weren't gratuitous but we also felt like
we were serving the truth and when you
got it very closely you'll notice that
what you see is a foot shaking water
dripping on the ground sound that we're
telling a lot of the story without very
directly showing what it is and it's
still pretty terrifying my thanks to Jon
Hamm Adam driver Jennifer Fox and Scott
Z burns